ça c'est cool c'est une vidéo sur
motorola vous le savez vous avez cliqué
vous êtes dessus je vais pas vous faire
la suppression à bien des fois en vidéo
des buts vides ou faire la surprise vous
savez pas de quoi on va parler je vais
vous le dire attention fait durer le
suspense non vous le savez vous avez
cliqué jeu complètement stupide on se
parle de celui là on se parle de celui
là il est là il est là il est là il est
là il est là il est là ça je peux le
faire tourner passe-passe motorola m'a
dit tu es à monsieur dreux est ce que tu
voudrais pas présenter le h 30
aujourd'hui pas au km autour on y va
donc aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec motorola
pour venir vous présenter le elles
seront nouveau smartphone haut de gamme
de motorola qui vient faire de jolies
promesses au niveau de l'écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à
144 fo combien draguer les gamers matin
donc intéressant on va regarder ça on va
le regarder ce smartphone ensemble il
est là la regarder alors le smartphone
est là on va le mettre de côté parce que
quand on regarde un petit peu ce qu'ils
moto a fait au niveau de la boîte alors
heads 30 pro 5 g 5 janv a déjà des
choses intéressantes on commence à
regarder la boîte de ce smartphone mais
juste avant de vous montrer
regardez ils nous marquent ici ready for
compatibles alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ready for ça veut dire qu'en fait
c'est le comment dire c'est la phase on
utilise motorola pour venir connecter
son smartphone sur un téléviseur ou sur
un moniteur ça vous change un peu
l'environnement et ça vous permet de
venir l'utiliser pour un peu de
productivité si vous souhaitez donc
celui là il est compatible avec ready
for c'est le nom qu'utilise motorola
pour ça 5 j'ai bien évidemment alors là
on a le nom du smartphone on le voit on
a le petit batwing c'est le logo de
motorola legault iconique d'ailleurs
qu'on voyait depuis très longtemps edge
30 pro ok c'est cool c'est millions ça
va bien mon petit lapin bombe à la même
chose sur tous les côtés voilà on a
sensiblement les mêmes informations ok
alors autre chose je voulais voir à
l'intérieur de la boîte vous le montrez
un petit peu alors attendez bon
forcément smartphone n'est pas dedans je
vais enlever on s'en doutera ici qu'est
ce que je vais retrouver une petite
coque transparente de courir monty hop
là ici on titille voire deux cartes sim
les infos sur le smartphone comment il
marche comment le lui mais comme on est
à table petite info un peu simple et
puis on a un truc qui est intéressant
regardez vous le voyez ça écrit ici
alors on pourrait se dire j'ai de la
recharge 89 et non vous avez de la
recharge 68 ça c'est la réalité c'est
comme ça alors c'est pas des sceptiques
parce que 60 kg elle s'est bien et ça va
ça va ça va rapidement c'est rapide je
sais plus parler c'est très rapide alors
ça c'est plutôt cool parce que
effectivement vous avez de la recharge
rapide aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
constructeurs vont amener la charge
rapide asti smartphones l'idée c'est
quoi c'est de se dire qu'au bout d'un
jour en jour et demi lorsque vous n'avez
plus vraiment de batterie si vous l'avez
d'ailleurs beaucoup utilisé vous serez
un petit peu moins d'un jour vous allez
vraiment beaucoup utilisé sur du gaming
notamment et bien vous le prenez vous le
branchez en un quart d'heure que votre
parti pour une journée c'est un peu
l'idée en fait qu'on a aujourd'hui au
niveau de la recharge rapide dans ses
smartphones donc ça c'est bien recherche
qui sont plus en être qu'un câble en usb
c'est ici de ce côté bloc de charges
inclues dans la boîte donc il faut le
signaler je leur mets là comme ça je
peux vous refaire la blague 82 x tu
crois ça me fait mal vous retrouver ici
des petits écouteurs alors ça c'est
plutôt bien et est très rare parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez vous si vous
le savez mais la loi française a modifié
un truc qui a pas longtemps jusqu'à fin
de l'année dernière les constructeurs
avaient pour obligation de mettre des
écouteurs filaires à l'intérieur pour
limiter l'exposition aux ondes au niveau
des smartphones depuis ça changeait pour
des questions environnementales
écologiques on n'oblige plus les
constructeurs allemands est né ici
motorola s'est dit tiens si on le
faisait si on le laissait donc vous avez
des petits écouteurs greffe et griffé
greffe et griffé motorola et non pas
je sais pas quelle autre marque c'est
bien motorola c'est maintenant cela en
usb c'est donc là c'est plutôt cool et
en plus vous avez des petits en bout à
l'intérieur de différentes tailles pour
s'adapter à toutes les tailles
d'oreilles donc ça c'est plutôt bien et
ça c'est assez marrant parce que là où
vous avez plein de constructeurs dans
cette gamme de prix qui ne met pas de
blog de charge et qui ne met pas
d'écouteurs si vous êtes à la recherche
d'un smartphone où vous allez avoir un
bloc de charge rapide qui va être inclus
ici directement et bien vous pouvez
aller chez motorola et si vous
recherchez également un smartphone avec
lequel vous avez des petits écouteurs
inclus à l'intérieur vous pouvez aller
chez motorola avec ce 30ème trop alors
ça c'est bien mais est ce suffisant pour
le directoire fait ce smartphone la
réponse est non parce que il faut quand
même regarder ce qu'il vous propose
c'est une jolie possibilité que nous
propose motorola ici n'est pas
suffisante pour que se dire on va
claquer tout de suite donc ça c'est déjà
un premier pas il ce premier point il
est cool deuxième temps qui est
intéressant c'est le smartphone c'est
design du smartphone alors ce design
moins intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement on retrouve ce côté
motorola bat oui alors je pas si vous
allez vous en rendre compte mais là il
ya un côté un peu holographique c'est à
dire qu'on voit vraiment de la
profondeur il ya deux modules photos que
j'aime bien parce qu'à côté assez
asymétrique en fait c'est bizarre parce
que ça dépend comment vous le regardez
quand je vois comme ça eh bien j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait il dit par
complètement ovale et qu'il est plus
large par là mais je crois que c'est
juste en fait un effet d'optique un
effet de lumière parce qu'il me semble
qu'il est en fait réellement ovale je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez et un
truc un peu marrant donc ça jamais rien
coûter un peu asymétrique est très
chouette vous retrouvez à la marque
motorola juste en bas alors après c'est
un grand classique ça reste aux
smartphones c'est à dire bouton de
volume là le petit bouton qui font
office de bouton pour l'allumer pause
1-2 qui fait également office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous appuyer sa
déverrouille c'est rapide c'est pratique
c'est bien on va retrouver ici un petit
haut parleur le micro la norme ce
nouveau bloc hélas assez malin parce que
regarder ils n'ont pas voulu la mettre
là pour dire ouais c'est moins joli de
mettre la norme série si on va la
planque et c'est une obligation faite à
haut niveau des fabricants de
smartphones regardait les mystères
l'annoncé vous l'avez écrit ici c'est
donc je pense assez malin parce qu'en
fait la plupart du temps vous le
retrouvez le dos des smartphones et
c'est pas très beau là c'est très
clairement un choix de se dire on va le
planquer on veux pas le mettre en avant
mais c'est là donc là vous le voyez
fabriqués par motorola
il est fabriqué en chine je crois que
c'est bloqué aulas made in china et vous
avez le symbole pour ne pas jeter dans
la poubelle le tiroir de karting qui se
situe là sur ce côté là vous n'avez
absolument rien sur le dessus vous avez
le micro pour la réduction de bruit et
puis voilà voilà voilà on a fait le tour
du smartphone merci beaucoup au revoir à
demain non on continue à regarder il est
dispo dans trois couleurs vous avait le
cosmo blue c'est celui que j'ai là que
j'aime bien tous très joli ce petit côté
bleu avec des petits et fait la
différence bleus un peu un peu vert
d'ailleurs un peu vert canard sur le
côté qui est plutôt banal il existe
également stade stardust white blanc
voilà clairement et vous l'avez en green
glaciers 1,1 et c'est un smartphone qui
fait 100 96 grammes qui n'est pas
extrêmement lourd ça c'est plutôt bien
et vous avez à savoir un corning gorilla
glass trois à l'avant mais également à
la haye parlons maintenant de l'écran
ici vous avez un grand écran très grand
et donc bien pour l'immersion pour le
gaming si vous voulez l'utiliser
également son côté divertissement films
séries là dessus il ya pas de soucis 6,7
poussée énorme mais aujourd'hui la
plupart des constructeurs vont vers des
très grands écrans vous avez un écran
oled écran oled ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que par exemple lorsque vous
souhaitez afficher et bien un thème
foncer tout ce qui va être noir ce n'est
plus que c'est l'état donc on va venir
économiser au niveau de sa batterie donc
ça c'est plutôt bien un écran certifié
hdr laisse plus full hd plus et qu'il ya
une particularité non négligeable qu un
des seuls aujourd'hui quasiment des sols
y en a qui le font mais très très peu à
vous proposer un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 144
hertz salir encore plus d'image par
seconde si vous le passez en mode 144 m
ça se passe juste ici regardez dans le
mode taux de rafraîchissement de l'écran
alors là il est en automatique c'est à
dire qu'il va switcher automatiquement
pour rester entre du 60 hertz où 144
hertz ça c'est plutôt intéressant si
vous souhaitez économiser que vous dites
j'ai pas besoin 44 r ce que je vais
économiser de la batterie vous le restez
en 60 hertz c'est-à-dire très bizarre
d'un point de vue logiciel parce que dès
que je change ça voyez ça me sort ces
jours mal aimé rester là en fait donc
lime et en 60 hertz et si je veux le
pousser tout le temps 144 est anjou 134
hertz tout le temps même lorsque j'en ai
pas besoin je lui 144 êtes vous pouvez
le pousser bond index a strictement rien
ce qu'il faut faire ici c'est l'essai en
automatique comme ça vous êtes pena ça
nous permet quoi ce taux de
rafraîchissement 344 ha sera
effectivement d'avoir des images
beaucoup plus fier d'y avoir une espèce
beaucoup plus fluide lorsque vous allez
bien jouer à des jeux alors pour autant
est ce que je ressens une très grosse
différence par rapport à des écrans qui
propose du thon un fléchissement de 100
verte la réponse est non ouah points
preuve je me fous des murs et bien c'est
rapide c'est réactif donc là je le sens
vraiment bien et sur un jeu comme astral
teneul sosa quand même vachement cool
j'ai aussi si un taux d'échantillonnage
tactique de 360 m donc ça emmène une
fois de plus l'expérience de guémy et
c'est vrai qu'on le voit ce smartphone
il est quand même vachement bien pour
tout ce qui m gainé vous avez derrière
reims un dragon 8 deux générations un
qui sera vachement cool un plat une
petite pirouette pour la foire et on en
parle plus donc ça c'est bien donc on a
un smartphone qui l'a vite qui est
réactif qui est taillé pour le gaming
vous avez 12 giga de ram gddr5 donc une
techno qui permet d'aller extrêmement
rapidement au niveau de la ram qui
apportera un peu plus de fluidité vous
avez du stockage en nuage fasse 3.1
rapide avec turin d'écriture ses 256 go
de stockage entre les machines
extrêmement moustey au niveau de la
performance vous voyez on a tout est
très très cohérent au niveau du taux de
rafraîchissement de l'écran au niveau du
taux d'échantillonnage est active au
niveau de la performance au niveau de la
ram au niveau du stockage donc si vous
voulez acheter ce smartphone pour le
gaming il est très bien il ya un autre
point qui est intéressant qu'il faut
voir c'est l'aspect audio parce que vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréo alors un
haut parleur l'a et un haut-parleur
c'est le haut parleur vous avez là qui
sera aux parieurs de renforts il y a
quand même du son ce que je trouve
intéressant si vous voulez c'est que là
je les pousse à fond alors c'est pas le
smartphone ou alors le plus de puissance
sonore c'est une évidence par contre en
étant à fond j'ai un son qui est quand
même plutôt bien avec de la rondeur avec
du gras on est sur un smartphone
attention c'est pas un truc de fou
furieux mais ça marche bien et le fait
d'avoir ces haut parleurs là
je le trouve quand même
assez grave alors il ya un script qui
est intéressant c'est vrai sur les
smartphones lorsque vous utilisez le
haut parleur qui est planqué ici qui
vous sert pour vos appels téléphoniques
la plupart du temps c'est un vrai
renfort en médium c'est très médium là
le haut parleur et pas trop médium le
sont toutes à restituer pas trop médium
un peu de rondeur alors qu'il sera pas
aussi rond que le haut parleur que vous
allez avoir la mesa confère déjà une
passe ya lisation ça donne un rendu un
peu plus cohérent qui est agressive donc
ça c'est bien c'est pas là je vous dit
pas tout sera sont le plus fort les
sanaa et lorsque je baise c'est pareil
ça marche bien donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il ya une réflexion qui a
été fait ici de la part de motorola de
se dire ce smartphone il doit être
taillée pour le divertissement donc on
voit également que pour le
divertissement aussi un très très bel
écran qui ont plus de satin écran 10
bits donc il va avoir un milliard de
nuances de couleurs donc ça ça me plaît
alors maintenant le truc un peu un peu
moins un peu un peu négatif que je vais
retrouver est-ce que je vous conseille
de bien faire c'est de venir dans vos
paramètres et on va en parler des
paramètres dans quelques instants parce
que c'est pas où vous aidera fichage et
dans l'affichage vous venez d'en
couleurs couleurs se situer juste là moi
je me suis mis en couleurs saturées
parce que si vous n'êtes pas en couleurs
saturées c'est très pâle ou regarder on
le voit là alors c'est sûr saturé c'est
un peu au dessus mais c'est pas grave ça
reste flatteur si vous restez en
couleurs naturelles l'écran passe sur un
côté un peu plus vers regardez la
différence la voyez là c'est plus bleuté
plus jeunes verts alors une fois de plus
la vidéo et colorisé donc sais pas si
vous allez bien vous rendre compte mais
je vous décris réellement mais ce qui
est très clair c'est que regarder ici là
les couleurs de ma plante de mon colibri
et hula hoop en mode saturé c'est
beaucoup plus beau c'est saturé
clairement et la salle n'est pas donc
les atouts qui marchent pas et lorsque
je reviens même la voyez bien je trouve
que mon écran il le rendu n'est pas beau
parce que j'ai un espèce de côté un peu
vert désaturer ça manque de contraste ça
manque de profondeur sur l'écran et
c'est pas bien donc par défaut lorsque
vous le prenez il faut tout de suite
allé dans vos paramètres vous allez tout
de suite dans affichage vous allez tout
de suite dans couleur et vous mettez en
couleurs saturées et là on respire mais
vraiment on respire lorsque j'aurai aimé
c'est pouvoir paramétrer la saturation
un peu moins peu plus saturation ça
aurait été bien parce qu'après je peux
venir changer ma teinte de couleurs mais
le changement de teinte de couleurs et
les pas dingue lorsque je viens en plus
chaud je récupère un truc un peu vert
c'est très bizarre c'est pas ça marche
pas du tout lorsque je veux en plus
froid je suis trop bleu mais c'est un
bleu qui est pas beau donc vous laisser
au milieu et vous aurez un bon équilibre
donc couleurs saturées vous rester comme
ça et ça va et ça convient et ça
améliore l'expérience sinon c'est pas
ouf très claire alors je vous parlais de
du point de vue logiciel on est ici sur
un android 12 on peut venir personnalisé
c'est une option que nous permet de
faire ici motorola donc le côté
personnalisation je le trouve pas mal je
sais jamais où il est parce que
l'expérience en fait logiciel c'est
vraiment tout cabossé et qui pour moi
n'est pas né ce n'est pas c'est assez
clair personnalisés voyez il me le
propose donc je peux dire partez pas mal
de choses je peux me dire personnalisé
ma disposition les couleurs les formes
des icônes laissons donc ça c'est bien
et ça c'est cool qu'on retrouve ici donc
ça bien je peux avoir des thèmes moi
j'ai mis ce thème là qui s'appelle siwei
parce que j'aime bien ses couleurs un
peu bleuté être le côté orange est un
peu chaud ça me plaît après je peux dire
modifier les son client n'était pas mal
de choses il ya différents thèmes qui
sont là ok je peux bien modifier mes
fonds d'écran également il y en a
plusieurs que choisir parmi les photos
donc why not ça ça me convient mais d'un
point de vue général je trouve que
l'expérience n'est pas clair bien que
lorsque j'arrive dans ce menu j'ai
aucune séparation entre rien mon oeil ce
volet n'est pas guidé surtout qu un ben
oui mon dieu tu te remets ça quelque
chose non ça l'est pas alors pour autant
est-ce que j'ai tous mes paramètres oui
j'ai tous mes paramètres bien évidemment
je vous ai montré l'affichage mais
lorsque je voyais je dois venir
rechercher faire un effort parce que
c'est pas clair voilà affichage c'est là
ok une fois que celui-là j'ai tout
localisation pareil au niveau de la
sécurité de la confidentialité j'ai tout
mais je trouve que c'est pas clair donc
il ya vrai l'eau à venir faire ici je
pense pour sexy fier l'expérience
logiciel une fois que vous avez vos
repères sa barre il n'y a pas de
problème mais en l'état on connaît de
meilleurs expériences ailleurs et c'est
vrai qu'ici c'est le truc un peu en
dessous à côté de ça et des choses assez
intéressantes notamment lorsque vous
allez me dire jouer vous avez un mode
jeu dédié vous allez pouvoir avoir
différents petits paramètres donc ça
c'est bien et c'est bien vu et bien
optimisé vous avez un petit menu moto où
vous allez pouvoir changer votre fond
d'écran stylisé et compagnie donc ça
c'est assez rigolo également voilà il
faut emmener à touches un poil plus loin
même s'il ya des choses qui sont quand
même relativement intéressante et ça il
faut le reconnaître rod sujet qui est
intéressant c'est la question de
l'autonomie de la batterie ici y en a
une grosse batterie de 4800 milliampères
heures et là-dessus motorola n'a pas
lésiné c'est bien c'est rapide je
voulais dit vous allez votre charge 68
watts donc ça c'est bien ça marche bien
et savent où leur charge rapidement
c'est du turbo power en 15 minutes vous
l'avez recharger à 50% donc ça c'est
cool une journée sans problème vous avez
également de la recharge sans fil 15
watts peut le faire si on le souhaite et
la recharge un verset 5 watts donc on a
un truc et cohérence un smartphone que
vous pourrez utiliser partout tout le
temps on a bien évidemment de la 5g
grâce au sang dragons 8 jonone on a du
wifi 6e donc à la maison vous pourrez
utiliser le wifi si c'est le wifi 6e
lorsqu'il arrivera chez vous double
signe 5 g/l ready for je vous ai dit
résistant aux éclaboussures ip 52 alors
ici n'ont pas voulu faire de
décertification ip68 je pense qu'ils
pourraient l'avoir parce que c'est une
question d'économie ça coûte moins cher
pour sortir le meilleur tarif peut-être
en tout cas il est certifié ip 52 aux
éclaboussures a minima et ça marche vous
avez également une sécurité logicielle
et matérielle avec syncshield du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé et en
plus de ça il ya un truc qui existe chez
moto s'intéressant à les voir sur leur
site ce qu'ils ont en étui folio avec un
stylet donc si vous voulez utiliser avec
un stylet vous pouvez le faire bon faut
l'acheter en plus sur le stand motorola
xoom est le lien en bas par la
description alors le truc qui est
intéressant et qu'il faut regarder c'est
toute la partie photo cette partie photo
vous le voyez elle est décomposé avec
trois éléments à l'arrière on va avoir
un capteur principal un grand temps de
50 méga pixels on ouvre à f 1.8 et il
est stabilisé optiquement bien on a un
pixel qui fait un micromètre et lorsque
vous venir regrouper plusieurs pixels 4
pixels en 1 vous arrivez un pixel de 2
micromètres qui vous permettra d'aller
plus loin notamment pour des photos nues
bon ok on passe rapidement ensuite vous
avez un ultra grand-angle 50 méga pixels
également en cours avec 2.2 qui vous
servira effectivement prendre des photos
avec l'ultra grand temps mais également
macro alors ça c'est pas mal parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de fabricants qui vous met
des hommes tif macro qui vous dit pour
faire de la photo c'est on accroche
c'est souvent du 2 août du 5 mégapixels
là vous passez par une ultra grand-angle
bonbons dans l'idée pourquoi pas et vous
avez un capteur de profondeur de 2
mégapixels que vous avec 2.4 pour le
mode portrait assez classique tandis
qu'à l'avant vous avez une caméra de
saïfi ouais ça c'est plutôt bien la
bonne caméra telle fille de 60
mégapixels touvre f 2.2 donc voilà pour
la confie la config allait bien elle est
sérieuse vous avez pas mal de petites
possibilités lorsque vous voulez tenir
shooter alors la version logicielle est
très très simple c'est très épuré ici
parce que regarder vous avez photo vous
avez vidéo et le reste est situé là
alors après vous avez tout ce que vous
voulez vous y retrouver mode portrait la
vision de nuit des fils de couleurs vous
pouvez pousser les photons 50 méga
pixels si vous le souhaitez des selfs it
group un poil plus âge le mode pro la
double capture lorsque vous venez faire
un peu de vidéo voiliers a picture in
picture on peut venir le faire là donc
il ya quelques petites options qui
existent qui sont assez marrante en mode
photo vous pouvez venir shooter voyard
et c'est très très simple vous n'avez
pas de tels objectifs attention ces
trucs qui manquerait un peu mais bon il
ya beaucoup de constructeurs qui
aujourd'hui ne met pas de télé objectifs
dans cette gamme de prix je vous parle
du prix dans quelques instants capteur
principal l'ultra grand-angle et là vous
choisissez le mode macro aussi sur
l'ultra grand angle mais c'est une bonne
macro et après voulait s'appuyer et vous
monte alors ça que j'aurais bien aimé
d'un point de vue logiciel voyez avoir
un petit bouton x 2 x 5 que j'ai pas
donc ici alors après 5,8 ifa vous monté
jusqu'à 1 x 10 numérique mais manque ce
petit bouton que j'aurais bien aimé
avoir mais qui n'existent pas ici après
vous voyez où je sais votre format de
photos et compagnie et lorsque vous
switchez en vidéo pareil on peut même se
faire de la vidéo macro ok on s'en fiche
un petit peu ultra-grand-angle vidéo
macro et leur regarder lorsque je viens
poussé ici le hdr 10 plus parce que je
peux le faire directement dans mon menu
à plage active le hdr 10 plus je reviens
là et bien là le plus filmé avec mon
ultra-grand-angle parce que il ne
fonctionne pas avec le hdr 10 plus
uniquement votre capteur principe a pas
de souci là-dessus oui lorsque je vais
pousser les choses ça me supprime le hdr
10 plus à me le dit et là je peux venir
filmer directement avec mon
ultra-grand-angle bien switcher alors
après je peux venir avoir au maximum une
résolution 8 kg ha à 30 images par
seconde 60 images par secondes ça
fonctionnera pas quatre cas je peux
aller jusqu'en
60 images par seconde mais si je veux
ici regardez poussé par exemple hop là
dans les paramètres mon âge dr death
plus je peux le faire mais il me le
barça sera uniquement ici sur l'objectif
principal sur du 4k à 30fps bon ok ça
posera pas réellement de soucis ici
voilà presque être une petite option en
plus ici micro activer désactiver ou pas
je suis assez content parce que je
trouve qu au niveau de la partie photo
motorola s'est amélioré l'année dernière
j'avais testé déjà des smartphones de
moto gt pas hyper hyper emballé par la
partie photo je trouve que là dessus ils
ont retravaillé un peu leur copie ils
ont amélioré l'histoire donc ça c'est
plutôt pas mal regardez là on est sur le
capteur principal or je vous ai fait
quelques petites photos le temps est
pourri aujourd'hui à paris donc vous
allez voir on fait pas de la magie ça
une photo toujours pareil sur mon grand
temps que ça fonctionne c'est pas mal le
résultat somme toute assez correct on
peut venir se rapprocher un petit peu
j'ai fait x 2 x 5 x 10 vous rendrez
compte quand x 5 déjà et jusqu'en fois
dit c'est pas extraordinaire x 2 on peut
un peu pas trop me croquer dans l'image
comme ont un grand capteur de 50
médiatique c'est ça nous permet de le
faire mais c'est pas non plus parfait là
on est sur l'ultra grand angle et grand
angle valais ok j'en fais un peu les
mêmes tests pour vous montrer pareil à
grand angle voyez ça fonctionne c'est
quand même assez bien dans l'ensemble au
point d'avoir un peu plus de piquer par
moments mais je trouve que la
colorimétrie est juste c'est pas sûr
saturé on a un truc qui est assez
correcte donc ça fonctionne l'ultra
grand temps que forcément ça va être
beaucoup moins précis parce que c'est un
ultra grand-angle voilà on fait pas de
la magie il n'est pas stabilisé donc
tout de suite avec moi ça ça pardonne
pas du tout on peut se rapprocher un peu
je vous le dis en x 2 mais au-delà de ça
on va éviter un fois ça vous le récupère
déjà un peu de bruit sur les panneaux
ici est bon faut dix histoires de se
marrer capteur principal c'est pas mal
ce mec il ya certaines personnes qui
vont vouloir avoir des photos un peu
plus saturés parce qu'on est habitué
avec certains constructeurs à mettre des
peaux plus de saturation un peu plus
punchy ici c'est pas le cas ils ont
vraiment fait je voudrais si d'entrée
naturelle et on le voit envoyé au niveau
des fleurs on pourrait appeler un poil
plus de saturation c'est pas le cas mais
bon ça fonctionne quand même l'ultra
grand temps que ce n'est pas hyper fan
envoyer c'est beaucoup moins précis et
puis après on peut venir ou d'un petit
peu en voie de battre un peu la même
chose pareil ici sur la mairie du 3e
arrondissement on voit bien la façade le
ciel aucune c'est pas mal c'est correct
c'est pas le meilleur photophone c'est
pas les meilleures photos je m'y
retrouver mais c'est correct et ça
permet d'avoir un rendu qui est correct
on peut faire de la macro alors une fois
de plus la macro et moi ça fait quatre
jours que les résultats sont pas hyper
simple c'est pas facile de venir faire
le point de trouver la bonne distance de
sortir la bonne photo en plus moi je
trempe donc c'est pas ouf donc bon la
macro ça me laisse un peu sur ma faim
mais bon voilà même si on est sur un
meilleur capteur je suis pas super
emballé donc le capteur principal une
fois de plus ultra grand-angle bon ça
fera ça fera son effet les différents
hommes je montre toutefois plus alors
les caméras de celle fi n est pas
extraordinaire bien qu'on ait un grand
capteur de 60 mégapixels je trouve que
le résultat est pas dingue alors là j'ai
une vraie tronche c'est parce que j'ai
c'est trop chaud at il dit à ce point
fut le trou chance moi je raconte même
pas l'histoire des poches sous les yeux
vraiment des postes où les yeux je
trouve que derrière briller rendu il est
pas beau sur l'arrière plan il ya un
côté un peu un peu bruitées voilà c'est
pas très apprécié et d'un côté ou de
l'autre moi ça me semble me convainc pas
je vous ai reçu un peu de maquereaux
histoire de vous montrer mais pas plus
et puis voilà on se refait un petit
shoot après classique et voilà voilà
dans l'ensemble donc je trouve que le
smartphone il va être pas mal sur le
capteur principal en x 2 si vous avez
beaucoup de lumière sur un ultra
grand-angle vous bougez pas les mains
skis k2 bat pour que tout le monde why
not mais bon voilà moi je trouve un peu
en dessous
regardez lâcher de la vidéo 4k 30 h dr
dix plus alors il ya des pigeons voilà
il ya une poubelle il ya la mairie du 3e
qui a derrière ici comme ça enfin petit
tour panorama et voilà je plutôt sympa
donc ça c'est la 4k 30 on peut faire
aussi de la ville car on peut faire de
la 4k 60 et du full hd donc la voyez je
suis un petit enregistrements comme ça
en ricains comme ça vous voyez tous ri
est ce qu'on peut faire envoyer quand
auront eu qu'à envoyer que le temps est
dégueulasse aujourd'hui les femmes avec
mika mais bon on lui casse est pas là on
aura tous que plus stabilisée on n'aura
pas d'agir 10 plus pour en avoir c'est
uniquement maximum de la 4k à 30 images
seconde vidéo offrant un tiers disent
plus donc la voyez comme ça va bien
filmé un peu de tous les coachs et sous
le temps parisien qui est magnifique
aujourd'hui comme ça voyez tout bon et
j'ai bien évidemment une caméra celle ci
alors c'est pas là qu'on aura la
meilleure qualité mais bros si vous
voulez vous voir dans le moniteur moi ce
que je pensais quand même c'est signé
votre caméra arrière de retourner le
smartphone comme ça voyait gros comme ça
c'est qu'il a battu deux côtés ssq
annuaire moi j'étais il perd chasse elfi
et voyez comme ça on peut se mettre au
fait on peut se mettre loin on fait ce
qu'on veut c'est assez pratique c'est
très pratique c'est très pratique c'est
très pratique
la partie vidéo bon on peut faire des
trucs après c'est pas un vidéophone on
peut sortir des petits souvenirs en
vidéo seront venir partager sur les
réseaux mais vous avez vu que pour moi
le hdr 10 plus là dessus il ya un peu un
peu poussif l'a8 cas je vois pas
réellement d'intérêt aujourd'hui sur ce
smartphone à mieux utiliser de l'a84 le
processeur vous permet de le faire mais
est ce qu'il faut faire la réponse est
non c'est un smartphone on peut trouver
à l'achat à la vente va vous en douterez
7 buts de motorola effectivement et bien
c'est ce h 30 pro il est au tarif de 999
euros en config 12 iliad ram 256 il ya
de stockage alors qu'est ce que j'en
pense moi de ce sport très clairement je
trouve intéressant sur toute la partie
multimédia gaming gaming divertissement
il est bien il ya de la performance y
montre les muscles motorola monte en
gamme ils ont fait des choix qui sont
des choix sérieux comme feront tous les
constructeurs qui veulent être dans le
premium donc là dessus pas de souci la
partie photo et pas mal elle est un peu
en dessous par rapport au reste même si
vous êtes des choses sympas sur votre
grand angle et que ça marche plutôt
plutôt bien c'est un smartphone que je
trouve qu'un bon format qui est pas trop
lourd qui est pas trop grand je suis
aussi un peu un peu moyen moyen sur la
partie software et parce qu'ils ont fait
le choix de ne pas travailler
d'expérience motorola je pense qu'il
devrait réellement marqué une expérience
motorola pour emmener les gens un peu
plus dans l'histoire parce qu'on a quand
même un logo qui est hyper connue parce
qu'un truc qui est typé et que ça serait
cool devenir sexy fier la partie
software ça apporterait vraiment un plus
et ça donnera un peu plus de
personnalité à ce smartphone bien qu'ils
soient déjà comme ça plutôt pas mal et
intéressant donc je trouve pas mal on
voit que motorola progresse si vous
voulez vraiment un smartphone solide
pour le gaming ou pour le multimédia le
motorola l'edge 30 pro est cool je
trouve plutôt joli je trouve intéressant
voilà pour mon retour sur ce smartphone
ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté un
smartphone de motorola mais un
smartphone pas un téléphone en parle pas
d'un téléphone via longtemps parle des
smartphones récents qui sont sortis ce
que vous avez un smartphone de motorola
et sinon est ce que vous pourriez vous
aussi tenter ce que vous pourriez aller
sur ce match 30 pro dit le noie en bas
en commentaire si vous vous êtes
intéressé si vous pouvez y aller au
québec le mois et si vous voulez pas y
aller dites moi pourquoi est-ce que vous
n'iriez pas aujourd'hui sur ice 30 pro
de motorola qu'est-ce qui vous
retiendrai qu'est-ce qui vous vous direz
pas encore je suis pas sûr pourquoi
dites le moi en bas en commentaire on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler de motorola il a parlé de plein
de marques voilà ça c'est cool robidoux
[Musique]